[Musique]
bonjour et pervis dans science orthez la
nouvelle émission d'été les 78
aujourd'hui nous sommes dues au château
de breteuil avec vous feriez mieux de
charolles administrateur du château
bonjour bonjour merci nous recevoir
alors aujourd'hui nous avons parlé du
château des extérieurs et des événements
à venir dans les dépendances du château
déjà on voit les aînés de charles
perrault
oui alors tout le côté féerique et
effectivement à l'extérieur du château
dans les dépendances
il y a huit scènes de contes de perrault
qui ont été reconstitués en son et
lumière dans les écuries l'ancienne zone
de chasse dans le lavoir vous vous
retrouvez comme sa peau d'âne cendrillon
le chat potté le dessus sur ton poule
ils sont tous là ce sont des petites
saynètes qui dure entre trois et sept
minutes en son et lumière que les
familles peuvent venir admirer tout au
long de la journée de 10h jusqu'à la
fermeture du parc
quel est le lien entre obtient alors le
lien était un lien de travail
collaboration de travail notre charles
perrault est notre ancêtre wing bottle
green day a été ministre des finances ou
tout début du règne de louis xiv et il a
eu charles perrault comme bras droit
ça c'était au tout début de la carrière
de zéro perreault a écrit les comptes
bien plus tard il avait 63 ans à
l'intérieur du château cette fois on
peut appréhender la vie déjà bien à
l'époque
le voir comme aux vielles comment se
rendre en compte anticipée l'envi alors
le concept de la visite du château de
bataille c'est de vraiment faire un
voyage dans l'histoire de france à
travers l'histoire d'une famille qui a
servi les rois de france
donc le visiteur se promène dans le
château qui est entièrement le blé est
très belle collection de mobilier et
d'objets d'art de vivre et puis il ya
les personnages de grévin qui
reconstitue pièce après pièce
différentes scènes de l'histoire de
france
lesquelles un membre de la famille est
intervenue et vous rencontrez comme ça
le ministre 2016 avec 8 16 et
marie-antoinette il ya le roi louis
xviii rencontrerez gambetta jolie terre
marcel proust
madame du châtelet qui étaient légères
et walter qui était une bouteille
voilà différents personnages de cire
pour agrémenter ce parcours historique
donc à ses personnages en cire ici ont
des objets dans la cuisine par exemple
ben oui toutes les pièces sont très
vivante il ya tous les objets usuels
dans le parcours au premier étage on
voit une ancienne salle de bain à
l'époque il n'y avait pas de courant et
puis au sous-sol du château bien sûr les
anciennes cuisines qui va de la fin du
19e siècle avec toute une très belle
patrie depuis casseroles en cuivre de la
belle vaisselle de laque piano en fonte
très grand tout est très vivant
permettant de croiser mais aussi musique
est bien ici on peut s'amuser aussi and
stainless games est de nouveau depuis
deux mois de juin 2000 va effectivement
plusieurs jours par semaine il peut y
avoir donc par petits groupes entre 6 et
enquêteurs vont mener une enquête au
deuxième étage du château dans des
pièces qui n'avait jamais été ouvert
jusqu'à maintenant
le concept c'est que le braz régal est
en séjour à pau tail et ça s'est
vraiment passé en 1912 préfecture
edouard viii d'angleterre est venue
passer quatre mois ici pour se
perfectionner en français et donc le
concept de lesbiennes c'est que un
attentat se prépare contre le prince de
galles quelques uns veulent attenter à
sa vie et donc une femme de chambre du
château convoque des enquêteurs parce
qu'elle a trouvé créé beaucoup de choses
anormales qui se passait et donc il ya
les enquêteurs vont devoir à force d'un
10 vous remontez comme ça que le fils de
légumes et au bout de 90 minutes
résoudre l'enquêté découvrir qu'ils
projetaient d'assassiner le prince de
galles lors de son séjour à rothen
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire ici
une histoire tout à fait visible vous
fuyez alors oui pendant le parcours de
la visite il ya en ce moment jusqu'au
1er novembre une exposition de costumes
anciens
l'exposition s'appelle breteuil ouvre
ses malles et nous avons ressorti de nos
mâles dans les greniers une vingtaine de
costumes qui vont de l'époque de louis
saez jusqu'à la première guerre mondiale
il ya le traîneau annick d'hommes
d'enfants en plus des traditionnels de
leur robe de soirée rock de valve que
les visiteurs pourront découvrir tout au
long de la visite
et donc ils sont disposés dans les
pièces en se brûlant dans les pièces
tout à fait dans les pièces de la visite
donc en plus des personnages les vins il
y a promu tuer comme ça quelques
mannequins portant des habits à ces
précieux bien sûr et on a évidemment
suivi la chronologie de la visite pour
placer les costumes d'époque
il ya aussi d'autres expositions qui
vont au mois d'octobre et les
spécialités mobile tout à fait il ya
beaucoup d'événements qui ponctuent tout
le mois d'octobre
playmobil ce sera les 24 et 25 octobre
donc sur tout un week end
c'est la troisième édition
1018 2019 avait déjà vu les contes de
perrault et l'histoire de france en
playmobil
cette année le thème ce sera de cinéma
donc beaucoup de films célèbres
reconstitué sur les dioramas antennes
mobiles
c'est tout orange 870 mètres carrés qui
est qui devient un univers de playmobil
les visiteurs pourront découvrir dans
toutes ces toutes petites scènes de
petits personnages
merci beaucoup à juninho charouz avoir
reçu mais je vous en prie
à très bientôt à bretonne merci beaucoup
d'avoir suivi cette émission comme vous
avez pu le voir il ya beaucoup
d'évènements beaucoup d'animations pour
les femmes aux tirs quant à nous on
retrouve bientôt pour de nouvelles idées
de sorties
[Musique]